y una hernia inguinal es la
protuberancia anormal del contenido
abdominal como por ejemplo el intestino
a través de un área débil de los
músculos de la ingle el intestino
prominente reside en lo que se conoce
como saco el diario en algunos casos las
hernias que no se tratan ocasionan
complicaciones por ejemplo si parte de
los intestinos se traba en el orificio
de la hernia puede interrumpirse en
suministro de sangre lo cual conduce a
la necrosis del tejido intestinal esto
se denomina hernia estrangulada si un
cirujano cree que usted corre riesgos a
causa de esta complicación probablemente
le recomendará una reparación de hernia
optativa la reparación abierta
tradicional de la hernia inguinal
requiere una sola incisión relativamente
grande las técnicas laparoscópicas más
nuevas requieren solamente una pequeña
incisión en forma de ojo de cerradura o
punción que generalmente producen un
periodo de recuperación más corto al
llegar al hospital para someterse a la
cirugía se le colocará una vía
endovenosa y es posible que se la
administró en sedantes que le ayudarán a
relajarse las reparaciones
laparoscópicas de hernia inguinal se
realizan con anestesia general por lo
tanto permanecerá dormido el tiempo que
lleve la operación se le insertará
temporalmente un tubo
respiratorio por la boca y dentro de su
garganta para ayudarlo a respirar
durante la operación también es posible
que se le coloca un catéter en la vejiga
para drenar la orina estos dispositivos
se retirarán al finalizar el
procedimiento una reparación
laparoscópica de hernia inguinal sin
complicaciones por lo general lleva
entre 30 y 60 minutos dependiendo de su
situación y la experiencia del cirujano
se elegirá uno de los dos tipos de
técnicas laparoscópicas laparoscopia
extra peritoneal o laparoscopia pre
peritoneal trans abdominal para acceder
a la hernia el cirujano utilizará
instrumentos cortantes denominados
trócares para crear tres pequeños
orificios o puertos en la pared
abdominal la ubicación de estos puertos
variará dependiendo de las preferencias
del cirujano y el tipo de procedimiento
uno de estos puertos por lo general se
realiza en la zona umbilical
luego se bombeará dióxido de carbono a
través del puerto umbilical para inflar
el abdomen y así poder visualizar el
contenido más fácilmente a continuación
el cirujano insertará el laparoscopio a
través del puerto umbilical las imágenes
de la cámara se proyectan en un monitor
ubicado en el quirófano
luego el cirujano pasará varios
instrumentos a través de los otros
puertos estos instrumentos se usarán
para separar el saco hernia no
y colocar una malla sobre el orificio de
la hernia esto evitará que el intestino
se retraiga a través del orificio
antes de retirar el laparoscopio el
cirujano observara la zona por última
vez a fin de detectar hemorragias u
otros daños al retirar laparoscopio se
deja en el lugar una válvula del puerto
por poco tiempo para liberar todo el
dióxido de carbono del abdomen
finalmente las incisiones en forma de
ojo de cerradura se cierran con suturas
o grapas y se cubren con vendas después
de la cirugía se les retirarán el tubo
respiratorio y el catéter y se lo
trasladará al área de recuperación para
monitorear lo de ser necesario se le
administrarán calmantes para el dolor
cuando puede ingerir líquidos se le
retirará la viendo venosa la mayoría de
los pacientes son dados de alta entre 3
y 5 horas después del procedimiento